Hallo zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast. Podcast für Suferos. Herzlich willkommen, auch von mir, von Stefan Tietze spricht gerade so ein. Wir sind so ein bisschen wieder nach Hause gekommen, so nach dem grossen Ausflug. Heimgekehrt, deswegen der Folgentitel auch, werden wir dann mal gucken, worüber wir so sprechen. Heimgekehrt vielleicht. Wir sind wieder zurückgekommen aus dem Universum, aus den unendlichen Weiten, zwischen dunkler Materie und V-Strahlung. Jetzt sitzen wir wieder hier, im Innenhof von Köln-Ehrenfeld. Weißt du, hier sind Gravitationswellen scheißegal. Scheißegal. Lichtgeschwindigkeit, wie viele Nullen hat es, ist es alles egal. Ich habe mir eigentlich vorgenommen, in dem Anna-Friebel-Interview noch so ein bisschen passig zu werden. Was haben Sie denn da vorne jetzt im Alltag? Was können Sie da jetzt aktiv von? Einfach mal so, weil wir, weißt du, hier kriegt man nichts davon mit. Gar nichts. In Köln-Hinterhof kriegst du nichts von Revitationswellen mit oder von sterbenden Galaxien. Weißt du, was mich interessiert heute? Ob ich draußen eine Jacke anziehen soll oder nicht. Das ist die Frage. Können Sie mir das sagen, Frau Frebel? Ne, können Sie nämlich nicht. Wo ist die Formel, die das berechnet, Frau Achsohn-Intelligent-Frebel? So, und dann gibt sie die Nummer vom Meteorologen und dann sagt er, jo hier. Gut, ich habe heute meinen schönen Sipper, habe ich heute bestimmt drei, vier Mal ausgezogen. Heute, ich kam hier rein in den Raum, habe ihn ausgezogen, habe ihn dann nach ein paar Sekunden wieder angezogen. Es gibt einen Punkt, ab dem man sich einfach festlegen muss, ab dem man sagt, ich kann jetzt nicht ständig weitermachen, ihn wieder auszuziehen, anzuziehen. Ich sagte das, ey, wir brauchen eine App, die einem sagt, was man anziehen muss. Ich hab heute ein paar App-Ideen, haue ich immer mal so aus. Eine App-Idee, also nicht nur eine Wetter-App, weil Wetter, warum interessiert man das Wetter? Warum musst du diese ominösen Einheiten wie Fahrenheit und Celsius und Luftdruck und Hector Pascal, das brauchst du ja doch alles gar nicht, wenn dir einfach einer mal sagt, heute ziehst du einen fucking Schal an, du Mongo, und das sprierst du oben rum. Oder zieht dir heute mal die dicken Schuhe an, die kleinen Scheissen, die kannst du vergessen. Oder zieht dir heute mal, heute ist typisches Shirt, Strickpulli-Wetter, sowas. Aber eigentlich besser wär's doch, wenn man der App sagt, was man jeden Tag anhat, und die dann schon weiss, bei welchen Temperaturen du was anhast, und du sagst dir zum Beispiel, heute hatte ich ein T-Shirt an, war ein bisschen zu kalt. Und dann sagst du, heute habe ich die Jacke an, die habe ich gar nicht angezogen. Nee, warum musst du bewerten? Die App soll dir sagen. Nee, aber du musst deine persönliche Information reinspeisen. Genau, einfach deine Garderobe. Idee, du kombinierst das mit der Zalando-App, wo man ja alles bestellen kann mittlerweile. Du kaufst automatisch das, was du brauchst. Nee, da klickst du an, was du besitzt. Dann weiss die App ja, was für Kleidungsstücke du besitzt. Glaubst du nicht, dass du im Zalando-Shops meine Designer aus den Underground-Modelabel-Läden aus Paris findest? Okay, sorry, sorry. Aber vergleichbares. Gut, vielleicht findet man dein Raffaello-Musselli-Pullover nicht oder deine Jogginghose von Pierre Modanini. Mein Giorgio Giorgini-Jogginganzug ist nicht vergleichbar. Gut, mit deinen Leinen-Leinen-Augen, die überall sagen, hey, das sind Leinen. Nein, vielleicht. Aber in meiner Welt der Haute Couture ... Das wird sich ja wunderbar an. Ja, das ist ganz fein. Das ist Lammfeld. Ist das Seide? Das ist gefaltete Seide. Lammseide? Lammfalten nochmal geseidet Aber ganz kurz, Seide ist das von den Raupen, was hinten bei den Raupen rauskommt, oder? Richtig. Kann man fragen, kann man aus allem Stoff machen? Weil dann kann man, wer hat das gesagt? Weil, also Raupen sind nur so kleine Geschöpfe, du kannst dich einfach so lange daran ziehen, bis du einen Pullover hast. Nee, aus dem Kokon. Die Raupen machen ja einen Kokon. Und dann musst du dir erstmal von so einem Scheißkokon den Anfang finden. Das st stelle ich mir vor. Ich habe schon mal so Maschinen gesehen. Raupi macht doch Fadenschuss. Ja, aber um sich einzufädeln. Ja, klar. Aber das ist der Faden, aus dem man das so macht, oder? Richtig, aber der Kokon ist aus dem Faden. Der Kokoniert sich ein, oder gucken die andere Raupen dir ein? Nein, nein, nein. Wie macht man das denn selber? Die machen das selber. Wie denn? Ja, natürlich, um dich herum. Ja, aber dann bist du doch noch in der Lage, bist du doch durch und kommst nicht weiter. Du kannst doch auch einen Iglu um dich herum bauen. Ja, weil du aus dem Iglu raus kannst und Steine von außen, wenn du dich selber einiglst. Du kannst dich nicht selber einigl. Ich schwöre euch, Leute, wo sind die Eskimos unter euch? Klar kann man sich selber einiglun. Wenn du Faden spuckst und du hast dich eingefädelt, dann kannst du nicht mehr weiter Faden spucken, weil du durch bist. Aber die haben ja ganz tausende Schichten von Faden. Ja, weil die außen anfangen. Aber woran? Da fangen die einfach ein Zentimeter von sich entfernt an, den Faden zu spinnen oder was? Woran hält der denn? So, das war's. Bullshit. Siri. Völliger Bullshit. Ja, komm. Siri, können sich Raupen selber einspinnen? Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das rieche. Ja, okay. Siri, vielen Dank an die Stelle. Danke an diese ganzen Zukunfts-Suppe übrigens, die irgendwann prognostiziert haben, dass man irgendwann so ein Device hat, mit dem man sprechen kann, die aber nie gesagt haben, dass man irgendwann, ja, Folgendes habe ich im Web davon für dich gefunden. Und dann sieht man die Fussballergebnisse von vor drei Wochen. Danke, danke, das hat man nicht in den Science-Fiction-Filmen. Science-Fiction, ich schaue mir keine Science-Fiction-Filme an, weil ich weiß, ich werde enttäuscht. Weil du enttäuscht wirst. Ich werde enttäuscht, ich sehe da irgendwie ... Meistens von dem Film. Von dem Film auch, aber vor allem von der Technik. Hey, ich habe noch keine Liebe in Robotern gefunden, wie her. Was? Ich natürlich. Wirklich? Hast du dich schon mal in ... Alter. Wie heißt der, von Lieferheld, Stephanie von Lieferheld verliebt? Nee, ich hab mich jetzt in den Imo. Ich hab jetzt einen
Rasenmäher-Roboter. Ja?
Also meine
Familie, also in der
Heimat, wo ich manchmal noch bin am Wochenende,
da haben wir jetzt einen Rasenmäher-Roboter.
Und ich bin schon, also
wir sind jetzt, ich hab mich wahnsinnig verliebt, ey.
Weil man muss sagen, ist ein Er.
Aber naja gut, man muss auch mal
aufwinden, er ist einfach wirklich wahnsinnig zuverlässig. Man sagt ihm, mähe einfach montags und donnerstags und er mäht montags und donnerstags. Aber wie macht er das? Fährt er so Kreise oder zickzack? Und das finde ich genial. Ich dachte halt, man muss nämlich draußen eine Begrenzung legen, eine Induktionsschleife. Wenn er da rüberfährt, merken seine Innereien, oh shit, ich verlasse gerade das Gehen. Also wie so eine Art Schnur oder was? Genau, so ein kleiner Draht. So einen kleinen Draht, den legst du einmal um den ganzen Rasen. Wenn er da drankommt, fährt er wieder zurück, weil er merkt, er verlässt gerade das Gelände. Dann dreht er sich random, Zufallsgenerator, irgendwo hin und fährt irgendwo hin, bis er wieder an diesen Dra Rad kommt. Wie genial. Und nach einer Stunde ist er einfach durch.
Und dann fährt er wieder in die Station.
Naja, aber wenn es wirklich zufällig ist, könnte es ja auch sein, dass er immer nur eine Reihe fährt.
Ja, aber es ist ja sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Das ist genauso wie mein, ich gehe fest davon aus, dass es ein Casino gibt, das nur Verluste macht.
Das bis jetzt noch nicht gewonnen hat.
Das bis jetzt noch niemand verloren hat, wo bis jetzt jeder gewonnen hat. Weil je mehr Casinos es gibt, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es bei einem Kasino genauso ist. Ja, es kann aber auch sein, dass die Vielzahl der Geräte, an denen man spielen kann und die Vielzahl an verschiedenen Spielen und unterschiedlichen Gewinnmöglichkeiten es noch ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher machen. Aber ja, vor allem wenn es bei ihm... Ja... Jetzt kommt er wieder mit seinem Ja-Singen-Sang. Ja, na ja. War ich wirklich am Tatort zur Tatzeit? Wir haben sie gesehen. Wir haben Beweise, wir haben Fotos, hier ist ein Video davon. Na ja. Wenn du, Stichwort, wenn du einen Terror anschlagst, Stichwort Schießerei, Amoklauf, wenn das passieren würde... Riesenrespekt. Respekt, ja, aber tatsächlich meine Vorstellung, weil ich ein Arschloch bin, in meinem Anhalt hat ja immer so Fantasievorstellungen, auch in der Schule immer so, wer ist der Amoklauf? Du hast da sehr viele, du hast ja auch an das Breivik-Buch gekauft, ich hab echt ein bisschen Angst. Als Recherche gründen. Du hast jetzt, wofür? Ja, genau ist meine Angst, als Recherche, wofür, warum, Was hast du vor? Leute, ich tue niemandem was zuleide. Ey, nein, ey, du kannst mir nicht, je mehr man über Amokläufe weiss, desto weniger tut man sie. Du kannst mir nicht erzählen, dass Breitweg ... Das haben die bei Rico aus der vierten Klasse aber nicht so gesehen. Nein, dann gab es eine Amokübung. Komisch, dass er nicht da war an dem Tag. Wie gesagt, man hat ja damals so Vorstellungen gehabt, dass man irgendwie dann alleine die Schule rettet und dann irgendwie kriegt man die Mädchen ab oder so. Meine Vorstellung, dass wenn irgendwie ein Amoklauf ist, ist immer dieselbe. Ich filme das Ganze und dann ist die Frage, was mache ich dann? Weil dann würde ich es nämlich an irgendwie die Zeitung verkaufen oder ein Bild verkaufen. Was, wie viel setzt man da an? Und das hast du schon so oft erwähnt, dass ich glaube, du hast dir das Buch gekauft und andere Bücher über Amoklauf, dass du das
genau planen willst und so weiter, guckst,
wie kann man da vielleicht sogar
irgendwie ins Fadenkreuz der Behörden schubsen,
dass du einen Amoklauf inszenierst,
um dann derjenige zu sein, der zuerst am
Tatort ist und ein Video macht.
Wenn also in den nächsten zwei Jahren ein Amoklauf
passiert, wo Florentin zufälligerweise
der Erste ist. Nein, das kriegt ja niemand mit, dass das Video
von mir ist, weil ich würde mich ein Bild an... Ja, weil du es als Pommes-Ruppelruppelweise der Erste ist. Nein, das kriegt ja niemand mit, dass das Video von mir ist, weil ich würde nämlich
ein Bild an... Ja, weil du es als Pommes-Ruppel ruchlädst.
Nein, ich habe einen Plan.
Und mich würde echt mal interessieren,
vielleicht haben wir Hörer, die sich damit auskennen, die irgendwie
Journalismus studiert haben oder sowas, die sich
richtig damit auskennen.
Wie viel Geld kann man für sowas verlangen?
Wie viel Geld macht Bild.de damit,
dass sie als einziges
Media-Outlet der Welt das Video vom Amoklauf haben? Best bestimmt richtig viel Geld. Oh, könnte man auch einen Film drüber machen? Vielleicht Jack Gyllenhaal vielleicht besetzen? Oder hier Tilda Swinton in der Nebenrolle. Ich denke mir immer, was ich machen würde, ich rufe bei Bild an und sage, pass auf, ich habe ein Video vom Amoklauf, ich habe dieses Angebot an alle Zeitungen Deutschlands geschickt. Und die Ersten, die zusagen, kriegen es, mein Angebot ist eine Million. So, ich habe dieses Angebot an alle Zeitungen geschickt. Hast du es dann auch an alle geschickt? Nein, habe ich nicht. Ich bluff nämlich. Ich rufe nämlich nur die Bild an, weil ich glaube, die Bild wird der meiste für Geld sein. Hört ihr das da draußen? Hört ihr das, liebe 30.000 Leute in Deutschland? Die wissen nicht, dass ich das bin, wenn ich irgendwann mal anrufe. Die denken, ah, da ist clever. Und dann sage ich, hey, ich habe alle Verläge Deutschlands angerufen, ich habe Stern.de angerufen, Spiegel.de, die können wahrscheinlich alles zusammen, egal, so, und habe gesagt, eine Million. Willst du der Erste sein oder willst du der Letzte sein? Ich will eine Antwort jetzt. Danke, dass Sie bei bild.de angerufen haben. Unsere Mitarbeiter sind alle im Gespräch.
Eine Million.
Bitte bleiben Sie in der Leitung.
Okay, klick jetzt auf. Drei, zwei, eins, wenn Sie in drei Sekunden nichts zusagen.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie bei bild.de angerufen haben. Alle sind alle Mitarbeiter gerade in der Leitung.
Eins, ihre Schuld. Dann rufe ich woanders an.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie bei bild.de angerufen haben.
Letzte Chance. Allerletzte Chance.
Sie finden nützliche Informationen auch auf der Website www.wild.de. Okay, klick auf. Tschüss. Fuck! Fuck! Und neben dir sind tausend andere Videos entstanden. Rita! Scheiße. Rita? Ey, fucking Live-League. Ohne Witz, wer ist denn so dumm und lädt irgendwas auf Live-League hoch? Wenn ich ein Video habe von irgendwas, verkauf das doch! Auch Periscope-Streams. Das ist wahnsinnig viel Geld wert. Ja, ich weiß, auch Periscope-Streams, die dann nachher Streams, die dann nachher mal gezeigt werden und so. Das ist so dumm, Filmes und Verkaufs, das ist so viel wert. Im Ernst, ich glaube, also ich weiß es nicht, vielleicht kennt sich jemand aus, ich glaube, dass eine Million eine realistische Zahl ist. Nagel mich nicht fest, aber ich würde sagen, es ist eine realistische Zahl. Mindestens 100.000 kriegst du auf jeden Fall. War aber tatsächlich schon mein Plan, das zu inszenieren, und zwar, ich habe in Berlin gewohnt bei einem grossen Helium-Luftballon von der Welt, wo man drauf fahren konnte. Und mein Plan war immer, der aus Helium, grosser Luftballon mit so einer Aussichtsplattform, und an Drahtseil wurde der so hochgelassen. Meine Theorie, mein Plan war, ich mache da eine normale Fahrt, ja, unauffälliger Typ, fährt da drauf. Ich installiere überall GoPros, oben auf dieser Aussichtsplattform. Dann, eines Tages, wenn dieser Ballon hochgefahren ist, komme ich mit einer Drohne, wo ich so einen Bolzenschneider dran installiert habe. Die Drohne fliegt an das Drahtseil, ich sicher in Entfernung, die Drohne fliegt an das Drahtseil, macht das Drahtseil kaputt, der Helionluftballon fliegt nach oben. Niemand weiß, was man tun soll. Rufen wir an die Polizei, kommen Hubschrauber, niemand weiß, was los ist. Ich habe die Videos der GoPros von Leuten, die in Panik geraten. Jetzt findest du aber nicht, weil du 800 Terabyte Daten hast von Aufnahmen von Leuten auf der GoPro. Da musst du erstmal die richtigen Dateien finden. Daran müssen sie doch schon scheitern. Nee, vielleicht klappt das. Und über das Drohnen, die Drohnen-Bolzenschneider, wenn du so weggegangen bist, so locker flockig. Ja, das kann man da installieren. Ganz Berlin wird noch in den Himmel gucken und wird diesen Weltballon sehen. Wie hoch steigt der dann? Hoch genug. Hoch genug. Ich glaube, es ist ein spannender, auch wirklich gefährlicher. Hier, Thomas Baumgartner ist auch mit einem Helium-Luftballon so hoch geflogen. Stimmt, in die Statosphäre gespielt. Vor allem, was hätte der gemacht, wenn er gesagt hat, ich spring doch nicht? Dann hätte er den kaputt gemacht und wäre runtergefallen. Oder hätte er dann Helium abgelassen? Wahrscheinlich hätte man Helium ablassen können. Der sitzt da oben und dann sieht man halt, wie er runterguckt. Und oh, das ist so, da geht einem eigentlich ein bisschen Schiss damit, wenn man diese Bilder sieht. das ist schon ganz schön gruselig. Aber du kannst dann auch nicht mehr zurückziehen ab einem Punkt, oder? Ne, vor allem, wenn du auch deine Eltern angerufen hast und so ein paar Medienunternehmen, die alle jetzt die Kameras draufhalten. Das ist wie wenn du den Bademeister anflehst, der gerade den Zehner zumachen will und du so, nein, nein, ich noch als Letzter, lass mich durch und dann gehst du und dann denkst du auch, oh scheiße, ich kann, ich muss jetzt springen, ich kann jetzt nicht wieder den Walk of Shame, den Climb Down Das ist wie wenn du dich beim Karaoke noch aufgeschrieben hast, nehmen sie mich auf die Liste, komm, und dann kannst du auch nicht mehr sagen, nee, ich singe jetzt nicht Eternal Flame mehr. Du kannst es nicht zurückziehen. Du musst Eternal Flame singen. Dann gilt's. Ah, das ist ein unangenehmer. Hattest du immer das Problem, vom Sprungturm zu springen, oder war es immer? Ja, ja, ja, nee. Ich war auch nie so, also Freibad habe ich mal gehasst, ich war, habe ich mal mit dem zwei Mal Freibad überhaupt. Und dann war ich einmal auf dem Zehn-Meter-Brett und dachte mir, no, no way. Dann bin ich runtergegangen auf den Drei-Meter-Turm und dachte mir, holy moly, das sind drei Meter, ich bin fast drei Meter gross. What? Das sind drei Meter? So fühlt sich mein Kopf jeden Tag. Das ist wahnsinnig hoch. Ich bin auf dem Ein-Meter-Brett gegangen und dachte mir, cool, da kann man auch noch ein bisschen springen, weil es ja diese Federfunktion hat. Das war mein Ding. Da bin ich runtergesprungen. Das war cool.
Du hast auch Schiss, oder?
Aber Höhnern habe ich nicht.
Nee, Höhnern sage ich auch nicht.
Fünfer ging irgendwann und dann Zehner im München Olympiastadion, was das fucking beste Schwimmbad der Welt ist.
Nicht nur, weil es da einen Zehn-Meter-Turm gibt, sondern, was ich immer viel interessanter fand, das Becken, in das man springt, wenn man da runterspringt, ist fünf Meter tief.
Das ist unglaublich tief. Und so tief sind sie normalerweise nicht. Und bei mir war immer die Herausforderung, ich will ganz nach unten tauchen. So mit Druckausgleich und Luft anhalten und so. Und fünf Meter ist wirklich tief. Also wenn du keinen Druckausgleich machst, hast du da wirklich nach drei Meter richtige Probleme. Wann war das? Da war es doch noch ein bisschen... Wenn du nicht mehr paddelst, dann da bist du doch unten. Nee, nee, nee, fett schwimmt. Da war ich so 15, 16 und da war ich auch noch Tauchkurs und das Geile ist, dass beim Becken, beim Sprungturmbecken vom Olympiastadion München gehen die, du hast ja immer so Leitern unter Wasser, so Einkerbungen in die Wand, Und diese Einkerbungen gehen bis zum Grund des Beckens runter. Ja, für Leute, die dann sauber machen müssen. Ja. Du wolltest fragen, warum. Du wolltest fragen, warum. Stimmt. Was aber super war, weil du, wenn du runterschwimmen konntest, konntest du dich so wie halt so eine Leiter, verkehrt rum, nur in die falsche Richtung, so runterhangeln. Ohest. Oh, das ist cool. Das war cool, da musst du nicht schön, da konntest du dich immer festhalten, nochmal chillen, nochmal Druckausgleich machen, und dann weiter. Ey, ich hab wirklich meine halbe Jugend in diesem fucking Becken verbracht, und es hat so Spaß gemacht. Ey, ich muss noch kurz was sagen. Ich hab eigentlich, ich hab ein Seepferdchen, aber es ist nicht rechtfertig, es ist nicht gerechtfertig. What? Ohne Scheiss. Ey, Schwimmbetrug von Stefan Tee, oder was? Ich schwimme seit Jahren ohne Genehmigung. Stefan die Flosse, Titzel, ernsthaft?ne Scheiss, ich schwimme seit Jahren. Das kannst du, das können wir uns noch rausschneiden. Was? Das müssen wir echt rausschneiden, das ist zu krass. Aber ich schwimme seit Jahren ohne irgendwas in der Grundlage. Aber wie hast du dir deine Sipfchen hier? Nee, pass auf, also früher, ich habe das krass, Schwimmunterricht, und die Lehrerin war so streng, und die hieß, kann man das sagen, Frau Schön. Und Frau Schön war so, und es war so lächerlich, aber Frau Schön war furchtbar, es war eine grausame, strenge Frau. Und dann hat sie, und ich habe das gehasst, und dann muss man da tauchen, also schwimmen und so, über Wasser halten, das konnte ich. Okay, da muss man aber tauchen nach einem Ring. Nie geschafft. Ich nächste Woche wieder hin, geheult, weil die ganze Nacht davor geheult, weil ich nicht hin wollte, wieder nicht geschafft. Aber was genau hat die Probleme bereitet? Luftanhalten, primär Luftanhalten, weil meine Todesschreie, die unter Wasser abstösst, die verbrauchen viel Luft, da muss man wieder nachatmen, ging nicht. Also habe ich das nie gemacht und dann habe ich wieder geweint und wieder geweint und dann am nächsten Tag wieder hin und dann plötzlich lag das Seepferdchenabzeichen mit meiner Uhrkarte auf dem Tresen und ich so, wow, ein Wunder, das ist ja Wahnsinn, ichnsinn, ich hätte dafür gebetet. Ohne dass du getaucht bist? Ich bin nie getaucht. Nie, nie getaucht. Moment, aber hast du es dann versucht? Oder musst du es nicht geschafft oder gar nicht erst versucht? Ich habe es manchmal versucht und nicht geschafft, aber nur weil ich Kopf unter Wasser gemacht habe, und habe gesagt, nope, das ist zu tief. Ich sehe den Ring da unten, ich sehe, wie tief er ist, das werde ich nicht schaffen, ich möchte nochmal wiederkommen. Aber am Ende hast du es bekommen, ohne dass du den Tauchgang absolvieren musstest. Das ist das grösste Wunder. Und seitdem, das ist auch, glaube ich, das Ereignis, warum ich denke, je länger ich warte, desto mehr lösen sich alle Probleme eh. Kenn ich. Und desto mehr musst du, du musst nichts tun. Alles fängt dir zu. Aber ist das eine, ich glaube, das ist im Grunde eine gute Lebensentstellung, zu wissen, es wird schon gut. Es ist auch deine Einstellung. Es ist auch meine Einstellung und bei mir ist generell der Regel Probleme so lange ignorieren, bis sie sich von selbst lösen. Jetzt möchte ich mir was als dein Arbeitskollege sagen. Das ist eine Arschloch-Einstellung. Ja, ist es auch. Du bist zwei Tage effektiv noch im Autorenraum, nee, ein Tag effektiv noch im Autorenraum. Zwei. An dem einen Tag haben wir die ganze Sitzung, also einen Tag, wo du effektiv verschreiben kannst. Und dann hast du halt diese Einstellung, alle Probleme lösen sich. Ja, solltest du mal kurz mal einen Insiderblick eingeben, warum ich diese Probleme lösen? Weil ich Überstunden mache, weil ich mich abends auch hinsetze und Aufgaben mache, weil ich noch nebenbei noch Dinge mache. Mr. Stephan, 17.30 Uhr. Und damit meine ich zwei Minuten. Du wählst doch alles auf Tarkan ab, du machst doch genau die gleiche Strategie. Natürlich mache ich die gleiche Strategie. Jeder macht die gleiche Strategie. Aber ich muss mich darum kümmern, deine Probleme zu delegieren. Und das ist genau der Arschloch-Move. Es macht schon einen. Naja, aber es ist so, ich glaube, im Endeffekt ist dieses es wird schon irgendwie gut werden, eine gute Einstellung. Ich glaube, es ist besser als dieses Tietze-Denken, das schaffe ich eh nicht, der Ring ist zu tief. Ne, das Tietze-Den ist es nicht. Na gut, ist der frühe Tietze, der Nichtschwimmer-Tietze. Der Ring ist zu tief. Der Ring ist definitiv zu fies. Fuck you, ich mach das nicht. Und kommt daraus hindurch. Und dann habe ich es aber irgendwann noch zum Silber, zum Silber im Abzeichnen geschafft. Bronze dann auch Bronze und Silber. Bronze und Silber habe ich noch gemacht. Und dann Freischwimmer. Nee, Gold gibt es ja noch, oder? Hast du dann auch immer noch deine verranzte alte Badehose angezogen, obwohl die schon durch war, wobei einfach das Abzeichen dran war? Man hat alles gesehen, aber ich wollte das Abzeichen behalten unbedingt. Und die Pädophilen am Strand dachten sich, hä hä hä hä hä hä hä hä hä.
Die haben das wahrscheinlich eingeführt. Ist das ein grosser Pädophilenplot, diese Abzeichen, die man auf dem Bade anzut.
Und die lösen sich auf, die Nähte.
Clever, wo wir gerade bei Epiden waren, ich muss mal kurz was vorstellen. Also ich glaube wirklich, und das ist immer nicht ganz unironisch, dass ich damit reich werde. Also das ist wirklich, das sagt man immer so, es ist immer diese Sache, ich habe eine Elbe erfunden, die wird die Rieche auf dem... Ich habe Telefon erfunden, ich weiß, ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ich glaube, das wird was. Genau, und ich glaube jetzt wirklich, dass es ist, weil es klingt vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen unhandlich, aber lasst es mal auf euch wirken, und es ist schon geil. Nicht klauen, bitte. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es rechtlich aussieht. Das reicht. Wenn du sagst, nicht klauen, bitte, dann kann es ja nicht geklaut werden. Ja, da muss man noch, weil das ist ja auch irgendwie unser Urheberrecht hier. Das darf ja auch niemand genau mehr so sagen, wir abspielen, was wir hier machen. Das ist ja auch urheberrechtlich geschützt. Ah, interessante Frage. Ob man es genau so sagen darf, weiß ich gar nicht. Ich muss kurz mal, also Copyright Stefan Tietze, Copyright das Podcast. Ab jetzt. Ab jetzt, für die nächsten fünf Minuten. Und zwar, die App-Idee ist folgende, man kann live Audio kommentieren, du guckst Fernsehen, zum Beispiel Fußball, Bundesligaspiel oder so, und wenn du willst, kannst du das kommentieren. Und du beispielsweise Micky Beisenherz und weiß nicht wer, gucken HSV gegen Hamburg und kommentieren das dann. Du hast keinen Bock auf den Sky-Kommentator oder den ARD-Kommentator und kannst dann deine Lieblings-Comedians oder deinen Lieblings-Podcaster, wir beide kommentieren Bayern-Spiel, keine Ahnung. Oder den ESC. Ja, natürlich, aber das ist natürlich die coolere App, da kannst du, du brauchst diese visuelle Ebene ja gar nicht. Du kannst einfach, vor allem, du willst es dabei nicht sehen, du willst nur hören, das ist so quasi Live-Podcast, nur halt kann jeder zu jedem Zeitpunkt machen. Ja, aber das ist auch Periscope. Du machst einfach nebenbei Periscope an, hörst Mickey Beisenherz, macht den Fernseher aus oder hast du das. Ja, aber das ist doch so umständliches Gestreamer. Stattdessen hast du einfach eine App, wo alle Ereignisse gerade drinstehen, die im Fernsehen laufen oder sowas. Da musst du dich für das Ereignis anmelden. Nö, du musst dich anmelden, kannst du einfach als jemand, der das hören will, kannst du das Ereignis anklicken, was du gerade gucken willst, siehst alle, die gerade dazu einen Live-Kommentar machen und kannst draufklicken. Ja, aber ich meine jetzt als Sender. Wenn ich jetzt Micky Beisenbergs bin, dann muss ich sagen, ah, ich will jetzt gerade dieses UEFA-Spiel kommentieren. Genau, meistens die grossen Ereignisse gibt es dann schon, wenn es kleinere sind, kannst du die neu anrichten schnell und kannst dann dazu live einen Stream raushauen. Das ist einfach ganz normal automatisiert. Und es geht noch weiter. Diese App kann zum Beispiel auch Regisseuren anbieten, einen Audiokommentar für die Filme zu machen. Heißt, wenn du zum dritten Mal in Mother gehst, weil es ein Megafilm ist, kannst du einen Audiokommentar von Darren Aronofsky hören im Kino. Stimmt, das hat der Rian Johnson. Genau, das hat vorgeschlagen. Erzähl das mal, ich finde das richtig cool. Ja, genau, das ist eine geniale Idee. Rian Johnson, der neue Star Wars Director, macht aus manche Filme, hat er das gemacht, dass er quasi zum Kinostart schon angeboten hat, einen Audiokommentar zu machen, wo man dann schon einfach so eine iPod-Kopf reinmacht, durch die man ja immer noch eine Menge hört, und kann dann, wenn man zum dritten Mal oder zum zweiten Mal im Kino ist, direkt schon einen Audiokommentar hören. Das ist so eine coole Idee. Ja, das kann man auch da drin machen. Oder angenommen, du hast Bock, durch London zu gehen, weiss nicht, was will ich sehen, gibt's einfach einen Audiokommentar von Guy Ritchie für London. Ja, aber wo läuft er denn hin? Dann gibt's eine Karte dabei, wo du einen Weg hast. Und der checkt, wo du bist und spielt dann das ab. GPS ist ja gar kein Step. Das wär geil. Oder für alle Museen können da ihre Audiokommentar. Einfach eine Audiokommentar-App. Das ist, glaube ich, echt schwierig, das unter einen Oberbegriff zu passen, aber Audiokommentar-App trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut. Also, um mal ein Beispiel, ich stehe jetzt, ich laufe durch Washington, stehe vor dem Weissen Haus. Und dann sagt die App, pling, hier hat Jake Gyllenhaal einen Kommentar gemacht. Wollen Sie ihn hören? Ja, Beispiel. Das ist das Weisse Haus. Kannst du aber auch direkt die Jake Gyllenhaal-Tour machen. Ich mache, oder die ganze Tour, oder ich, ja genau. Ja, da ist eine Karte, da brauche ich bei, wo du dann, weil es gibt ja auch ein Fussgängernavi im Handy, der dich dann die ganze Stadt lotst. Olli Schulz zeigt dir Hamburg immer auf dem Ohr. Fände ich schon eine coole Sache, man bräuchte halt viele coole Prominente dafür. Aber die Audio-Kommentar-App finde ich geil. Und da können auch alle Museen, weil es nervt doch tierisch, dass du bei jedem Museum immer noch diese grossen Kopfhörer dir leihen musst. Wie bullshit ist das denn? Du hast doch ein GPS-Gerät, das ist doch genau in deiner Tasche. Gib einfach ein, wenn du ein Stockpack bist, und dann soll die App sagen, wo du gerade bist. Samuel L. Jackson führt dich durchs Metropolitan Museum. Genau. Tony Tarantino schickt dich durch Kalifornien. Mhm. Das ist, finde ich, cool. Dann das Regisseur-Feature, dann das ... Generell mal, generell in so Video-on-Demand-Zeiten, die daran angebrochen sind, du hast keine Audiokommentare mehr. Niemand kauft sich mehr Blu-Rays. Ich muss mir Blu-Rays kaufen, nicht weil ich den Film sehen will, die Filme, die ich mag, kann ich mir auch bei iTunes kaufen, nein, weil ich einen Audiokommentar haben will. So, das ist doch scheiße. Und dafür kommt die grosse Commentary-App von Stefan M.T. Ich finde den Live-Aspekt nicht so stark, dass man Sachen live kommentiert, weil, wie gesagt, wenn gerade das Fussballspiel läuft, kann Mickey Beissner es auch Periscope anmachen. Genau, es ist halt eine Sammlung davon. Es ist eine Sammlung, wenn du wirklich so ein Audio-Ding hast. Es kann ja sogar über Periscope laufen, es kann ja sogar verbunden sein. Nur ich finde diesen gesammelten Aspekt halt cool, dass du halt live was guckst und gleichzeitig alles gerade hast zu einem Event. Bei Periscope musst du halt aktiv gerade danach suchen, wer das gerade machen könnte. Lass einfach eine App, wo das gesammelt ist ist. Die Leute kommentieren gerade alle Werder Bremen, Bayern München, die Leute kommentieren gerade Dortmund, Wolfsburg und alle anderen kommentieren gerade Fluchtecke-Riebig auf ProSieben oder sowas. Aber kann da jeder auch seine eigenen Kommentare reinstellen oder muss man prominent sein? Das finde ich auch wichtig, weil ich habe auch Sportjournalismus studiert teilweise und da wollen halt alle immer Kommentatoren werden, haben aber nie die Chance, das mal auszuprobieren oder so. Die wenigsten setzen sich dann wirklich mal vor ein Spiel, was sie aufgezeichnet haben und kommentieren das dann nach. Das machen wirklich wenige Leute, aber das ist, glaube ich, der einzige Weg, um das zu lernen. Und dann, wenn das einfach jeder machen kann und sich dann vor das Spiel setzt und das kommentiert, wie cool. Weil alle schimpfen sich immer auf die Kommentatoren. Zeigt mal, dass ihr es besser könnt. Und das noch zu Städten und weiß ich nicht was. Und die Parcours-Leute können Leuten zeigen, wie man durch Berlin parcourt. Und können dann, keine Ahnung, so Tony Hawk. Du hast schon das Video für das Startup im Kopf. Tony Hawk zeigt den Leuten, wo man langscaken kann. Warum Parcours, Mann? Parcours ist immer noch cool. Warum trägt er Dreadlocks, Mann? Warum Stefan? Wie Pokemon Co-Go. Wann hast du das gedreht alles? Das war jetzt am Wochenende. Ist das Stacy Urico? Was zur Hölle? Ja, Stacy. Okay, aber wie heißt die App? Das sieht man erst ganz am Ende, oder? Megaphone. Ich schwanke zwischen Commentary oder Megaphone, weil da habe ich schon das Logo. Megaphone habe ich schon diese große Tröte, da habe ich schon als Logo auserkommen. Eine große Tröte hast du beim Megaphone. Ich mache mal kurz das Licht an und du bewertest die App. Ja, ich finde die App, also erst mal die technischen Probleme gehen mir massiv auf die Nerven, dass er immer automatisch alles schon runterlädt und bei mir alles die Festplatte sofort voll macht bei meinem Handy. Und das ist immer abstürzt. Das ist ständig abstürzt, finde ich. Ich mag das Design gar nicht, dieses helle Weiss auf gelbem Hintergrund. Ja, er ist extra hellweiss. Ganz unangenehm, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, hat Jake Gyllenhaal zu viel Zeit? Der hat in jeder deutschen Stadt jede Strasse kommentiert. Ja, ist zu viel. Meinst du, ist zu viel? Das finde ich ein bisschen zu viel, ehrlich gesagt. Und ansonsten, ich meine, wirklich Kommentar von William Shakespeare zu einem Shakespeare-Taterstück. Ja, danke Pommes Ruppel, wie viele Sterne gibt es bei iTunes? Also, wären die massiven technischen Probleme nicht vor Ort, fände ich es ganz cool, deswegen drei Sterne. Ich überlege das wirklich, auf Kinoaspekt zu beschränken, weil das als Elber auszuhauen ist eine Idee, die Rian Johnson exklusiv, glaube ich, manchmal macht, finde ich so genial, weil das, ich glaube, das bringt auch wieder Leute ins Kino, zumindest so die Hardcore-Fans, mal in den Film zweimal zu gehen, um dann einen Audiokommentar zu haben, weil Audiokommentare sind so unterschätzt. Das finde ich eine super gute Idee, aber wo
veröffentlicht er das denn? Ich glaube,
einfach auf einer Website. Weil das kann ich
mir zum Beispiel als Podcast vorstellen.
Und weißt du, was die App noch kann? Die hört,
wenn der Film gerade an welcher Stelle ist,
heisst du musst dein Kind dein Handy nicht rausholen.
Jetzt kommen wir weiter.
Und da gibt es ja auch diese App, wo du
bei der Werbung spielen konntest,
da konntest du einen Quiz machen und so, während der gehört hat, dass gerade eine Werbung läuft, Da konntest du Gutscheine sammeln. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die hieß. War auf jeden Fall um die Werbepause angenehmer zu machen. Eigentlich damals eine coole Idee gewesen. Das könnte man auch machen, dass die App genau checkt, wann sie angehen muss, weil sie das hört. Ja, gefällt mir, gefällt mir. Ich hatte jetzt eigentlich eher so einen Podcast im Kopf, wo man dann verschiedene Regisseure einlädt, ihren Film zu kommentieren, bevor sie rausbringen oder so, und dann halt den Podcast und kann sich dann die Folgen anhören dazu. So ein bisschen halt wie Audioflick von Etienne, die es halt aber halt privat machen, nicht die Leute, die es damit zu tun haben. Aber coole Idee, coole Idee. Ich weiß nicht, ob Audiokommentare so beliebt sind. Audioflick, glaube ich, hat auch nie so Weißt du, das ist mir egal. Ich will die primäre App machen, die mein Leben verbessert. Wenn ich mir vorstelle, Fussball zu gucken mit Leuten, die jetzt kommentieren, wenn Bastian Pastelka plötzlich HSV kommentieren, keine Ahnung, aber das wird auch lustig. Oder wenn der plötzlich, weil der ist ja auch so ein riesen Edgar-Wallace-Fan zum Beispiel. Angenommen läuft bei Kabel 1 die dutzendfache Wiederholung von Edgar Wallace und dann macht er das, kommentiert er das dann einfach live für einen, weil er viel darüber weiß, das würde doch die Fernsehen revolutionieren. Du würdest doch viel öfter mal Fernsehen gucken mal wieder. Ich glaube, das Problem mit der App ist, sie braucht halt von Anfang an große Unterstützung von wichtigen Leuten. Wie kriegst du das? Wie schaffst du es, dass du Pazewka kriegst in der App, die es noch nicht gibt? Ich bin doch vernetzt, wir sind doch in den Medien, da kommen wir doch, ey, willkommen an Johann König, locker dran, willkommen an Olli P. Johann König und Olli P gebe ich dir. Mit viel Glück vielleicht Olli Schulz und die Hamburg-Tour, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Kannst du vielleicht sogar vom Tourismuszentrum Hamburg, vielleicht kriegst du dann ein Sponsoring oder so. Ein Zehner. Ein Zehner, war auf die Kralle. Komm, nehmen Sie ein Zehner. Schön auf die Heizung. Aber das war mein Pitch. Ich hoffe, dass, also wenn da jemand draußen ist, der das programmieren könnte. Bitte, nicht die Idee wegnehmen. Bitte niemals selber machen. Fragt mich vorher nochmal um Rat. Stefan Tietzes Kommentar. Redet euch ein, dass ihr mich dafür braucht. Weiterhin. Ich bin Visionär, bitte. Hey, ich habe noch andere Ideen, dann können wir noch mehr Geld machen. Ich würde mich wahnsinnig freuen, wenn man da mal weiterkäme. Vielleicht ist es so ein Podcast-Ofer-Community-Ding,
das wir diese App rausbringen. Ich finde es
gut, vielleicht würden dann die Leute im Kino auch mehr die Klappe
halten, wenn sie wirklich nebenbei noch was zu tun haben
und nicht ständig kommentieren. Wenn sie nie bei Musik hören
oder Podcasts.
Ich glaube, ich habe mich noch nie so einsam gefühlt, als ich
in Berlin mal alleine im Kino war und
während der Werbung und bevor die Werbung
losging noch einen Podcast gehört habe.
Da saß ich da, einen Podcast gehört und alle um mich rum, ah Popcorn, hi hi, und das Pärchen hat sich mit Popcorn gefüttert, so, ha, ha, ha, und du sitzt da und hörst irgendwie Nerdist und dann so, oh, ich schalte meine eine einsame Unterhaltung aus, um die nächste einsame Unterhaltung in den Kinofilm zu beginnen. Aber hat Spaß gemacht, habe ich... Was war es für ein Film? Das war das zweite Mal American Hustle. Oh, Megafilm. Ja, ja. Ja, fand ich auch sehr gut. Bei mir läuft es immer mehr rauf aus auf dem Kino, wo Leute fucking die Fresse halten einfach. Ich will, wenn ich mal ein bisschen Geld habe, will ich irgendwo ein Kino eröffnen, wo wirklich einfach die Leinwand ist so durchsichtig von der hinteren Seite und ich sitze hinter der Leinwand aus so einem Schwimmbad, Bademeister, Podest und bin so in der Kalaschnikow-Generhand. Richtig, ich bin in der Mitte der Leinwand, sehe alles mit so einem Nachtsichtgerät, sehe alle Leute und wenn einer redet, Film angehalten, ich stehe auf mit meiner Super Soaker, schieße ihn ab, gehe wieder zurück, Film geht weiter. So, dann habe ich so einen grossen Button neben mir, wo ich drauf auf, Film geht aus und zack, zack, tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch, ey, Leute, wollen wir heute Abend in Spider-Man gehen, ne, Spider-Man, aber nicht in dieses Scheiss-Kino, nicht in dieses Halt die Fresse-Kino, das ist so nervig und dann ist man die ganze Zeit nass und an da wieder Film angehalten, das ist die Scheiss-Experience, nee, sobald jemand dreimal, zweimal reden raus, einmal reden Super Soaker, zweimal reden rausgeschmissen. Und der Film der Zulnerstäter, jemand der zum zweiten Mal rausgemissen wird. Ne, wer einmal rausfliegt, hat Hausverbot. Oh, streng. Wirklich keine Gnade, keine Gnade. Einfach damit alle wissen, hey, ich gehe hin, um einfach entspannte Zeit zu haben. Was ist der klassische Popcorn nach vorne umfallen und über alle anderen Sitze drüber? Habe ich nicht so viel dagegen. Da kriege ich kostenloses Popcorn. Ich mag Popcorn, das an mir klebt. Popcorn wird besser, wenn es an deinem Körper klebt. Wenn du nach dem Kino noch so ... Da beneide ich ja viele Menschen mit Ausschnitt, wo so ganz viele Popcorn noch drin sind und man dann so auf der Heimfahrt noch so snacken kann. Ich war am Wochenende in Hamburg im Savoy-Kino. Was ein geiles Kino. Du warst in Hamburg? Ja. Mensch, hätten wir uns so ein bisschen schön über die Reeper waren. Habe ich dir gesagt, ich habe ein paar Mal angerufen. Schön auf meinem Fädel, meinem Kiez. Ich habe dich ein paar Mal angerufen, du hast mich weggedrückt. Und zwar habe ich auf diesen, hinten gibt es dann einfach Sitze in der Loge. Loge! Loge in Hamburg! Loge! Wo man sich dann zurücklehlegen kann, weil die Sitze dann, wenn man sich
reinsetzt, so zurückfahren, dann liegst du quasi und vorne hast du so einen kleinen
Hocker, wo du deine Füsse drauflegen kannst. Wie genial! Und auch eines der wenigen deutschen
Kinos, wo du salziges und süsses Popcorn gemischt kaufen kannst. Geil, das ist immer
geil, ja, das ist gut. Ich habe noch M&Ms drüber gemacht, das ist wirklich perfekt.
Oh, Stefan, du bist ein Lehmann, was hast du gesehen? S. Excuse, ich hab tierische Angst dazwischen. Ja, hattest du Angst? Ja, schon. Also, fand ich nicht besonders gut den Film, aber der Clown war schon gut. Also, ich muss wirklich da mal Props loswerden an das Kostümdepartment und Maske, weil das ist schon ganz schon ganz schön krass. Der Clown sieht wirklich wahnsinnig gut aus. Das ist so ein originelles, cooles Design. Ich hab wirklich jedes Mal, obwohl er ja auch teilweise lange im Bild war, und anders als viele Monster, die man so kennt, die man immer kurz sieht, und dann am Ende erst der grosse Reveal kommt und man die ganz sieht, sieht man den die ganze Zeit schon, er redet ja auch die ganze Zeit, aber immer gruselig. Also wirklich, das ist einfach ein cooles Design. Schaut sich an. Ja, der Film steht und fällt mit dem Ding, ne? S. Ist das der beste Name? Killerclown? Ja, Killerclown finde ich nicht schlecht. Der böse Clown S. Ich finde, S ist so ein fauler Name, weil jeder Horrorfilm könnte S heißen. Das ist also alles kann S heißen, Godzilla kann auch S heißen. Heißt ja halt nicht Godzilla, sondern S. Aber er heisst Godzilla. Also viel coolerer Name als Der Clown aus S. Oder Honey by Lecter. Oder Scarface. Oder Bambi. Das sind coole Namen, die in der Runde bleiben. S finde ich immer ein bisschen uncool. Das ist so der Erste, der den Film so nennen wollte, hat ihn so genannt. Ja, Stephen King. Visionär. Finde ich uncool. Nee, finde ich ... Ist doch dumm an der Kinokasse, oder? Ich hätte gerne Treibkarten für Es. Für was? Es. Was war sie? Für das, für diesen Film. Welchen Film? Der Film heißt Dieser Film. Ach, ja. Die mit ihren Namen auch immer. Fällt es mehr ein, was ist denn mit Hotelmania?
War sowas. Ich war am Wochenende in Hamburg und ich habe eine furchtbare Erfahrung gemacht. Und es ist mir total, ich muss es dir einfach erzählen, weil es nachhaltig im Kopf geblieben ist. Da lebt jetzt ein Freund von mir, ein guter Freund, den ich besucht habe, und der ist an eine WG gezogen. Und diese WG besteht aus einem weiteren Mädchen,
gleichalterisch wie wir ungefähr, und
einer älteren
Dame, die Besitzerin der Wohnung. Und diese
ältere Dame, was heißt älter, die ist um die
vierzig, so, und die ist Dirigentin,
mir cool, und die hat einen Sohn,
der ist zwei Jahre alt.
Das ist das Alter, wo man noch nicht so richtig sprechen kann,
wo man noch nicht so richtig auf dem Damm ist,
wo man noch nicht so richtig emotional,
wo man noch klein ist, sehr klein.
Und da war ich halt dann
Vielen Dank. Das ist immer das Alter, wo man noch nicht so richtig sprechen kann, wo man noch nicht so richtig auf dem Damm ist, wo man noch nicht so richtig emotional, wo man noch klein ist, sehr klein.
und da war ich halt dann, bin morgens
aufgewacht, so wollte er ins Bad gehen
und dann kam es zu dem
Zwischenfall, dass
der kleine Junge im Bad
und das Bad ist nicht abgeschlossen, weil
der Junge kann halt nicht, er kann halt die Tür nicht
aufmachen und er könnte sich halt einschliessen
also hat diese WG sich dazu entschlossen,
dem kleinen Jungen nicht
einzuschliließen und keine Möglichkeit zu geben. Und dann hat er halt gebadet. Der hat halt dann da gebadet. Und dann bin ich wieder... Alleine, oder was? Er hat alleine gebadet, Mutter war nebenan in der Küche, er hat so Spielzeug und so und ich sofort wieder rausgegangen. Das kannst du jetzt nicht bringen, ich kann nicht zu dem Jungen ins Bad gehen. Und dann hat die Frau aber gesagt, nee, geh da ruhig rein, geh da ruhig rein, auch sehr eindringlich gesagt. Also, dann kannst du auch nicht gehen, das ist schon gut, ich will damit nichts zu tun haben, dann noch mal Business. Ich bin also ganz schnell rein, in dem Moment hat sich der Junge auch umgedreht, also ganz unangenehm, war mir halt mit seinem, also er war mit der Bauchseite mir zugewandt. Ich habe ganz schnell die Hände gewaschen, hatte aber keine Brille auf, weil es am morgens noch war. Du bist aufs Tor gegangen, oder was? Nee, ich wollte nur so frisch machen und Zähneputzen. Eigentlich habe ich da nicht mehr gemacht. Dann wollte ich die Hände waschen, drehe mich um, habe nur ein Handtuch da hängen sehen, nutze das Handtuch, Merke, es ist kein Handtuch, es ist ein Bademantel,
an dem ich mich gerade gerieben habe
und gehe wieder raus.
Und der Junge wurde zweisparig erzogen
und hat dann auf Polnisch mir hinterhergerufen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was er gesagt hat.
Wahrscheinlich war es sowas wie,
dieser widerliche Pedo hat an meinem Bademantel gerieben.
Ich habe die Tür zugemacht und bin einfach
wieder in das Zimmer von meinem Kumpel gegangen.
Wie unangenehm war das denn? Aber die Mutter hätte jetzt auch echt in Kauf genommen, dass du vor ihm aufs Toll gegangen bist. Ja, ich glaub schon. Oder dich geduscht hättest oder sowas. Ja, nee, das ging nicht, weil er da war. Ach so. Aber das Ding ist schon wirklich... Na ja, gut, mit zwei ist man schon, glaube ich, fast gehirntot einfach, oder? Also gut, natürlich viele infantile Sachen behält man auch und so, aber... aber ein interessantes Konzept, ein Kind zu erziehen als in einer WG. Also ein Kind in einer WG zu erziehen, wo die ganze Zeit fremde Leute sind. Ist nicht eine WG der schlechteste Ort für ein Kind einfach? Ja, vor allem, es ist ja keine WG-WG, sondern es ist so eine, Leute wohnen da mal zwei Monate WG. Und das heißt, du hast die ganze Zeit fremde Menschen drin, das ist doch schon ganz schön heftig für ein Kind, das zu verarbeiten. Naja, das gewöhnt sich halt dann dran vielleicht, du wirst dann irgendwann auch cool drauf. Das war aber schon unangenehm. Das kann ich mir vorstellen, er ist so eine richtige ... Aber sein Bademann war richtig weich. War ja auch weich, hast du ihn mal. Er war auch sehr weich, aber der Bademann war auch sehr flauschig. Es wäre so lustig, so, ich müsste baden. Ja, geh einfach zu ihm in die Wanne.
Okay.
Aber es war ein bisschen eindringlicher.
Geh einfach zu ihm in die Wanne.
Geh zu ihm in die Wanne.
Sitze da in der Wanne.
Ach Gott, wie unangenehm.
Naja,
das war mir in Hamburg.
Schade, schade. Hättest du auch bei mir schlafen können.
Wir haben ein grosses Bad.
Ich habe ein paar Mal angerufen. Da wird dir gefallen, Lars hat auch so einen Roboter-Staubsauger. Oh, es sind die Besten. Der aber tatsächlich immer ... Hat der Namen? Warte, wie hieß der nochmal? Siehste, das ist nämlich genau das Ding, während du nachdenkst, kurz die Anekdote. Es gibt halt Alan Turing, der den Turing-Test erfunden hat, nämlich dass Roboter, also die die Frage gestellt hat, wann sind Roboter endlich so weit oder AIs, dass man denkt als Mensch, man spricht mit den Menschen. Und das ist halt, dieser Roboter macht das halt komplett obsolet diese Frage, weil alle Familien selbst ihren Staubsauger-Roboter schon Namen geben. Holy shit, du brauchst nur etwas, was irgendwelche Bewegungen wiederholt, dann kannst du dir schon Namen geben geben. Der von Lars heißt Dödel. Und ich glaube, Lars will mir da so ein bisschen was so durch die Blume sagen. Weil ich habe mal gesagt so, ah cool, dann kann der auch mein Zimmer saugen. Und dann meinte er so, bei dir liegen leider zu viele Sachen auf dem Boden, da würde der hängenbleiben. Und ich dachte mir, ah ja, okay, gut, dann halt nicht. Dann bleibt die Tür halt zu und dann kommt er nicht rein. Jetzt habe ich aber schon ein paar Mal den Dödel-Roboter bei mir im Zimmer gefunden, wie er tatsächlich hängen geblieben ist auf irgendwie Taschentüchern, vollgerotzten Taschentüchern hängen geblieben ist. Und da dachte ich mir schon so, warum kommt er jetzt rein? Will Lars mir so zeigen, so, ah, hier kommt man leider nicht durch, hier bleibt er leider immer hängen. Und Lars hat ihn letztens auch,
und das weiß ich nicht, aber ich bin mit,
er ist nach Hause gekommen und mit ihm
und er war im Bad und lag
auf dem Rücken.
Was ist da passiert?
Das war echt so, wo ich mir dachte, jetzt versucht er mich
doch zu verarschen. Das ist doch ein Gag
von ihm. Ich hab ne Idee.
Ich seh mich schon mit Kreide den Tartart
bemalen. Der ist, pass auf, Herr Duschvorhang, manchmal geht man morgens drastisch aus der Dusche, der Duschvorhang geht aus der Dusche raus, am Boden schweift er, der Roboter kommt, saugt sich in den Duschvorhang rein, da er vertikal hochsteht, saugt so ein Stück hoch und dann kippt er raus. Geht er aus, weil dann merkt er, okay, ich hänge mich festgesaugt, geht aus und kippt um. Ja, aber da dachte ich mir echt so, das ist jetzt schon mehr. Das ist schon gruselig, du kommst nach Hause und der hängt dann irgendwie so auf dem Regal auf der dritten Stufe. Man denkt sich, das solltest du eigentlich nicht können, Kollege, aber gut. Am nächsten Tag hat er irgendwas an die Wand geschrieben oder so. Ich brauche neue Batterien. Eigentlich sollte das nicht gehen. Ich habe mal gehört, ich bin jetzt im Formel-1-Fieber. Nein! Und da habe ich gehört, diese Ansaugung, also die müssen ja in Kurven wahnsinnig schnell fahren. Damit die nicht umkippen, haben die vorne diesen Frontflügel, der sehr darauf bedacht ist, dass das Auto auf den Boden gedrückt angesaugt wird. Das wird so sehr angesaugt, dass es sogar auf dem Kopf fahren könnte. Das Auto, ein Formel-1-Auto, kann, wenn es massiv beschleunigt, könnte es so eine typische Need-for-Speed-Sache machen. Ach, so ein Looping-Fahrer. Es könnte so ein Looping fahren und könnte einige Meter an der Decke bleiben. Und ich meine sogar einige hundert Meter. Auf jeden Fall einige... Das ist schon ein Unterschied. Kann es an der Decke bleiben und fahren, weil es so angesaugt wird. Wenn der Staubsauger jetzt richtig doll ansaugt, könnte er vielleicht auch in die Wand hochfahren. Aber sind es dann umgekehrte Tragflächen oder wie? Wie ein Flugzeug nur andersrum? Genau, andersrum. Ein Spoiler ist auch ein Flugzeugtragfläche nur andersrum. Ein Spoiler weiß ich nicht. Das ist dann manchmal auch eher um die Luft hinter dir zu ordnen und sowas. Ich dachte, Spoiler drückt die Hinterreifen auf die Strasse, damit du mehr Energie auf die Schraubt trieb. Also du willst ja auch nicht zu viel Reibung haben. Ja. Weil je mehr drauf bist, desto mehr Reibung hast du ja auch. Das willst du ja auch nicht, weil du sollst auch schnell sein, die Reifen sollen nicht haben müssen. In der nächsten Ausgabe, Ralf Schumacher erklärt unsere
vier Fragen an Ralf Schumacher.
Der Podcast driftet ein bisschen
ab.
Ralf Schumacher kommst vor allem.
Nicht schlecht.
Der Podcast driftet ein bisschen ab.
Wir werden zum Expertenbeutel.
Special Interest Podcast. Wir haben
sehr konkrete Fragen. Formel 1, ey.
Formel 1, auch so ein...
Ich will mal einen Formel 1 Podcast. Hat nur eine Folge dann auch auch aber egal. Ja, und es geht um Mika Heckenen. Ja, du bist in einer ganz komischen Zeit. Du bist in den 90ern in der Formel 1 gefahren. Total. Sagt mir mal einen Skispringer. Steffen Freud. Du bist nicht so der Skispringer. Ich glaube, Wintersport ist im Süden Deutschland Wintersport beliebter als im Norden. Ja. Ja? Ja. Skispringen war bei uns ein grosses Ding, auch bei meiner Oma und so. Sven Hannawald. Sven Hannawald, sehr gut. Severin, Severin heißt er, Severin Freund, oder nicht? Nicht schlecht, du bist schon Sportcrack, oder? Nee, ich habe Sport studiert teilweise auch ein bisschen. Sportjournalismus habe ich studiert. War wirklich ein Drittel meines Studiums. Da habe ich so ein bisschen was aufgeschnappt, aber auch schnell wieder vergessen. Ich bin nicht so ein Sport-Crack, nee. Aber ich gucke, das ist halt so ein typischer Sonntagnachmittag von mir, wo man einfach so rumsappt und dann auch mal gerne beim Sport hängen bleibt. Aber gab es nicht mal auch diesen Algorithmus, der die ganzen Daten eines Fussballspiels, also Ballbesitz, Tore, wer hat das Tor geschossen und so, eingespeist bekommt und dann einfach einen Artikel schreibt über das Spiel und der nicht zu unterscheiden ist von einem Artikel, den Sportjournalist geschrieben hat, weil im Grunde verpackst du ja die Daten, die da sind, irgendwie in Text. Ich war auch ein riesen Arschloch in diesem Studium, was auch immer. Das war auch immer mein Standpunkt. So, vor allem mein Standpunkt war immer, ey, weil die haben es immer wahnsinnig ernst genommen, auch die Dezenten, die dann kamen, haben das immer für so eine Wissenschaft gehalten und meinten, ja, die Artikel müssen, und da habe ich immer gesagt, Leute, das ist Unterhaltung. Sport ist Unterhaltungsjournalismus. Ihr müsst, es ist scheißegal, wie ordentlich fakten treu der Artikel ist, Hauptsache es ist unterhaltsam. Sport ist unterhaltsam. Und das war immer eine Haltung, die niemand verstanden hat, aber meiner Meinung nach ist Sportjournalismus, also es ist die absolut richtige Entscheidung, jemanden wie Olli Welke da hinzustellen und du brauchst da keinen Sportgenie hinzustellen, sondern einfach einen unterhaltsamen Menschen. Das ist einfach, das ist ein cooler Abend hier, den wir zusammen das mehr als Sport, als Unterhaltungssendung verstehen, als als Sport, Wissenschaftssendung. Sport ist irgendwie so ein komisches Zwischending, also wenn du jetzt mal sagst, so keine Ahnung, so Wissenschaft, Kunst, Sport, Unterhaltung, so weißt du, zum Beispiel auch so einen Film, kannst du ja auch als Kunst besprechen, irgendwie, so einen David-Lynch-Film, da kannst du ein ernstes Buch drüber schreiben, was dann auch nicht mehr wirklich Unterhaltung ist, kannst du aber auch irgendwie was Reiss daraus schreiben, aber Sport ist in so einer Ist eine Zw Zwischenwelt. Es ist einerseits für manche Menschen das Ernsteste der Welt und
da gehen Leben drauf und die investieren wahnsinnig
viel Geld und Leben, aber auf der anderen Seite
ist es auch scheißegal, aber alles ist irgendwo scheißegal.
Der Rundfunkbeitrag wird ja massiv
diskutiert immer die ganze Zeit, sagt man,
man kann doch nicht Geld von mir nehmen für Rundfunkbeiträge
und für ZDF, ARD, die geben das
doch für Schwachsinn aus und so und
die, sobald Olympia
oder sobald Fussballsachen gesagt werden, das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr, weil da geht so viel Geld für drauf, wird sofort werden Petitionen geschrieben, Proteste, weil also so wenig Unterhaltung ein Stellenwert hat beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Programm, so viel hat Sport. Das ist Leuten so wichtig. Sport ist denen so wichtig. Egal, auch wenn Olympia niemand guckt und man sagt, die Leute, aber das ist halt auch wahnsinnig teuer, sagen Leute, wir steigen nicht aufs Dach, wenn ihr keinen Olympia macht. Sport ist wirklich extrem beliebt bei Leuten, immer noch. Aber dann ist es ja mehr als Unterhaltung, dann hat es ja schon einen kulturellen Wert, so wie, keine Ahnung, Opern, die auch subventioniert werden, weil sie nicht genug Geld einspielen, aber du sagst, die braucht man halt, also Olympia zumindest dann auch ein bisschen, also gutes Fußball und so nicht und so. Dein Formel
1, das ist ja ein Gassenhauer.
Formel 1!
Schon viele auch die Geräusche. Warst du schon mal schön
am Nürburgring, mal schön
vor Ort, mal schön ein bisschen?
Nee, aber da waren jetzt Freunde von mir, die waren
jetzt für das 24-Stunden-Rennen da,
ist der Nürburgring, glaube ich, und
dann haben die, dann ist es wohl üblich,
sein mit Graffiti was auf die Strecke zu schmieren. Und dann haben die, dann ist es wohl üblich, mit Graffiti
was auf die Strecke zu schmieren.
Und zwar nicht auf der Formel-1-Strecke,
sondern auf der 24-Stunden-Rennstrecke.
Und das bleibt dann auch da, halt für immer.
Das kriegen die nicht ab.
Wie lange braucht man da für eine Runde beim 24-Stunden-Rennen?
Ich glaube, neun Minuten, zehn Minuten.
Da fährst du ja hunderte von Runden.
Ja, klar.
Worauf ich hinaus wollte, dass die ganze Strecke wird so sauber, ordentlich für Gran Turismo abgefilmt, dass das Graffiti, jedes Graffiti im Gran Turismo landet. Die sind einfach wahnsinnig Gran Turismo-Fans und wollten sich darin verewigen im Spiel. Und demnächst Gran Turismo ist deren Giftgrüner Tag. Und dann schreiben sie, eine grosse Forsa ist besser oder sowas. Genau. Clever, nicht schlecht. Gran Turismo habe ich gerne gespielt, war eines der Spiele, die ich gerne gespielt habe. Obwohl ich Formel-1 und Fahrerei so im Real Life völlig uninteressant finde, fand ich das cool. Es hat irgendwas sowas Beruhigendes, so genau der Linie zu folgen und irgendwie so genau die Ecken zu treffen und dann nur hundertstel Sekunde rausholen. Ich spiele sowas gerne, während ich Podcasts höre. Ja. Weil das, das ist eine gute Nebenbeschäftigung. Ich habe mir jetzt einen Beamer, ich habe einen Beamer geholt, ich habe von meinem Vormieter einen Beamer übernommen und das war jetzt so ein bisschen so ein Gedöns, weil ich habe den lange nicht aufgehängt, weil ich ein Trottel bin und faul, habe den jetzt aber aufgehängt, der hängt immer noch, wo ich sehr froh bin, weil das ist recht schwer und den muss man an der Decke installieren, das ist nicht so einfach und ich traue so Dübeln und Löcher bohren ist immer so ein... Dübelbel, da ist man auch da muss man, ich stelle mir vor, man war wahnsinnig überrascht, das hält jetzt? Aber ganz im Ernst, das hält jetzt? Dübel ist für mich etwas, das nur in der Praxis funktioniert. In der Theorie null. Am Ende hast du dieses Ding und du ziehst an dem Schrauber und denkst so, wow, der ist richtig fest und ich könnte mich jetzt da dranhängen und der würde wahrscheinlich halten. Aber in der Theorie denke ich mir so, aber gut, du drehst den halt rein, du spreitst den halt so richtig raus, der ist lang und der spreitst so richtig dagegen, da ist viel Kraft drauf, weil du drehst ja, aber das wird ja übersetzt in viel mehr Kraft nach außen, das ist ja ein grosser Hebel, weil du drehst ja viel, du bewegst viel, aber die tatsächliche Bewegung in die Wand rein ist sehr klein, also du hast einen grossen Flaschenzug. Ja, genau. Ein Zehntel der Kraft wird in Bewegung umgesetzt. Das heißt, deine zehnfache Kraft wird verwendet, um den da reinzudrücken. Und nächste Woche zu Gast. Der Chefinnier von Fischer Dübel. Das wäre geil. Ist eine deutsche Firma übrigens. Haben die Dübel erfunden, ja. Genau, Fischer Dübel. Und es ist eine Firma, glaube ich, die ist eine der krassesten, mit dem meisten Umsatz und so weiter. Und die machen nur diese Dübel, die haben die erfunden. Ey, Dübel sind eine feine Sache. Das ist eine deutsche Erfindung. Riesen, riesen Quantensprung für mich. Und da habe ich mir jetzt natürlich auch, jetzt habe ich einen Beamer, jetzt habe ich eine geile Heimkinoanlage, jetzt kann ich auch schon mal nochmal schön Battlefield auspacken. Ich glaube, ich werde wieder zum Gamer. Ich glaube, ich werde wieder richtig Gaming erfunden. Du hast heute eine Gaming-Tastatur kam hierher. Ich habe heute eine Gaming-Tastatur geballert und es wird richtig intensiv. Und da auch mal, ich weiß nicht, ich habe Angst, dass ich da wieder ein Loch fall, dass ich dann wieder Gran Turismo zockt die ganze Nacht und zu nichts mehr komme. Wir sind anfällig für Löcher. Wir sind richtig. Total. Löcher sind unser Ding. Also man fällt in Löcher überall. Überall sind Löcher für einen geschaufelt. Ich habe echt Probleme, irgendwas zu genießen, außer Essen.
Bei Essen denke ich mir, oder so eine Flasche,
schöne Flasche Cola, die mache ich mir schön
kalt, eine Roten schon Rosé,
schön, aber sobald ich einen Film anschaue,
denke ich mir, ah, nicht lieber einen anderen Film,
nicht lieber einen tieferen,
künstlerischeren Film, nicht lieber was
von Hitchcock anschauen. Und wenn ich
ein Buch lese, habe ich dann
schlechtes Gewissen, dass es nicht ein tiefgründigeres Buch war oder so. Alles außer Essen kann ich nicht mehr Und jetzt ist es ein sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, jetzt, genau. Und das ist eigentlich schon falsch, weil du sollst ihn eigentlich unterhaltsam genießen. Ja, aber wir sind halt in einer Branche, wo einem das hilft. Also wo man auch nicht mehr ins Schrott gucken sollte, dann bildet man sich halt nicht mehr weiter. Aber eigentlich, ich glaube... Damit will ich sagen, ich könnte einen Transformer schreiben. Nee, ich glaube, eigentlich eine reine, ehrliche Leidenschaft hilft dir mehr, als wenn du jetzt sagst, oh, ich muss dir die David-Lynch-Filme nachholen, weil ich sie in Erste sein will. Wenn du einfach sagst, ich habe jetzt mega Bock auf den neuen Fast and the Furious aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Ich glaube, es hilft dir mehr, eine echte Leidenschaft
zu haben, als das zu über...
Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe auch überlegt heute,
bei mir ist mehr so Opportunitätskosten
Ding. Gucke ich eine Folge Curb
und da gucke ich aber gerade die neue
Folge Silicon Valley oder so, halt
alle nicht. Also da verpasse ich die halt alles.
Die Opportunitätskosten sind halt riesig.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt überlegt, das mit
so kleinen Polls zu lösen,
die man jetzt bei Instagram machen kann.
Ich frage einfach Leute, was ich gucken soll.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020 Die Abboten-Tiscos sind halt riesig. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt überlegt, das mit so kleinen Polls zu lösen,
die man jetzt bei Instagram machen kann.
Ich frage einfach Leute, was ich gucken soll.
Und dann sollen die mir sagen, was ich gucken soll.
Dann habe ich, ich muss die Entscheidung muss folgen. Aber da fühlst du dich dann auch verpflichtet,
das dann tatsächlich zu gucken?
Ja, oder ich mache einfach den Coinflip.
Klassischen Coinflip mal wieder einführen.
Den haben wir auch verloren, oder?
Ich könnte das gar nicht mehr, den so locker so hochflippen. Doch, ich fl Ich flipp ab und zu schon noch, Keu. Ehrlich? Ich will, das braucht man machen. Was ich gelernt habe, ist, dass wenn man eine schwere Entscheidung vor sich hat, soll man sagen, ja, bei Zahl nehme ich den Job, bei Kopf nicht und dann wirft man hoch und dann worauf hofft man. Und dann weiss man das, was man wirklich will. Meistens macht man das aber aus einem guten Grund rationalisiert. Und deswegen wird auch das nicht ändern, aber du verstehst es wahrscheinlich. Ich dringes bewusst sein. Clever! Entscheidungen sind schwierig, ne? Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, warum so etwas wie Götter und so ein beliebtes Konzept sind, die dann die Entscheidung abnehmen. Es gab ja auch in der Antike so ganz merkwürdige Rituale, wie man auch in der Kriegsführung und so auf Opfer und so gea, das war dann irgendwie so, da hat man dann, keine Ahnung, vor der Schlacht ein Lamm geschlachtet, Lamm die Kehle aufgeschnitten und wenn das Lamm irgendwie so und so hingefallen ist, mit den Füssen nach oben, dann war das ein schlechtes Oben, hat man die Schlacht verloren, aber wenn es irgendwie so hingefallen ist, mit Bauch nach unten, hat man die Schlacht gewonnen und dann war das irgendwie das Götteurteil. Ich stehe mir gerade vor, wie das so umfällt, wenn man sich die Kehle, angenommen mit dessen Lammfolie, du schleichst sie von hinten an, schneidest die Kehle durch, was genau muss jetzt passieren, dass das Bein, dass es mit den Beinen nach oben liegen kann? Ja, im Todeskampf rollt sich das dann hin und her, keine Ahnung. Aber es gibt dann auch historische Berichte davon, dass wir die Feldherren einfach mal so drei, vier Ziegen geschlachtet haben, bis mal eins auf dem Bauch landet, bis man gesagt hat, ja, jetzt haben wir das Go der Götter, komm. Und wir haben keinen Ziegen mehr. Wir haben keinen Ziegen mehr, aber es ist trotzdem merkwürdig, weil man irgendwie trotzdem sich besser fühlt, wenn einem die Entscheidung irgendwie abgenommen wurde, wenn man gesagt hat, die Götter wollten ja, dass wir kämpfen. Und dann ist es nicht so gut gelaufen. Also schon, also diese Entscheidung, jemandem zuschreiben, der sie nicht gefällt hat, ist echt eine mächtige Kraft. Okay, wir fällen jetzt in ein paar Entscheidungen. Ja. Okay, Curb oder Seinfeld? Seinfeld. Schon beruh ich's, weil ich Seinfeld nicht so viel gesehen habe. Aber ich habe es gesagt, weil es cooler ist und intellektueller und der Klassiker. Und es war jetzt schon falsch. Nein, die richtige Antwort ist Curb. Ich habe an Curb mehr Spaß als an Seinfeld. Ja, und jetzt? Weiß ich nicht. Aber das ist nicht so cool. Ich will aber auch cool wirken für den Podcast-Hörer. Genau, das ist nämlich das Problem. Okay. Cirrus-Wolken oder Kolumbus-Nimbus-Wolken? Kolumbus-Nimbus-Wolken. Einfach, oder? Er ist relativ einfach. Wobei Cirrus-Wolken ja die Chemtrails sind. Ja, das stimmt. Und da ist mehr Fun, da ist mehr Fun. Okay. Kleist oder Mann? Kleist, das ist leicht. Okay. Einige von Kleist oder Mann?
Kleist, das ist leicht.
Okay.
Einer von Kleist ist der Beste.
Cola, ist aber gut.
Goethe oder Schiller?
Goethe.
Goethe!
Du bist aber auch wo ganz anders gerade.
Simpsons oder Family Guy?
Simpsons.
Du sagst Family Guy, ne, weiß ich.
Ja. Was findest du besser. Freud oder Lacan? Jesus. Freud. Von dem habe ich mehr gelesen bis jetzt. Du machst von einem anderen Podcast. Du versuchst mich jetzt in irgendeine Ecke zu drehen. Ey, ey, ey, ey. Okay. Rocket Beans oder BDF? Das ist schwer. Das sind zwei verschiedene Sachen. Du kannst auch nicht sagen, linke Arm oder rechte Arm. Stefan oder Lars-Erik-Pauzen?
Lars-Erik-Pauzen. Definitiv.
Das wurde von der lustigen Rubrik zum Ernst. Zum Ernst. Fuck. Mutter oder Vater?
Oh Gott!
Nein, das kann ich nicht beantworten. Deine Mutter.
Oh. Ja.
Naja, damit kann man sich nicht mehr retten.
Mehr Entscheidungen. Jetzt bin ich dran.
Okay. Apfel oder Banane? Ja, Banane. Es ist nicht so schwierig. Würdest du lieber nicht mehr hören oder leider das Lottozettel verloren haben, mit dem du 10 Millionen hättest gewinnen können? Ja? Leider das Verschludert haben. Leider im Auto vergessen und dann nicht mehr gefunden. Ich wette, das ist mir schon dreimal passiert, weil ich erinnere mich noch daran, wie ich Lotto gespielt habe, aber ich erinnere mich nicht mehr daran, wie ich die Auslosen geguckt habe. Pass auf, folgendes Szenario. Du hast Lotto gespielt, du hast alles freigerubbelt, du hast 10 Millionen Euro gewonnen. Meine Frage war ein einfacher. Du hast 10 Millionen Euro gewonnen. Du rufst alle deine Freunde an, du rufst deine Bianca an, in die du schon ewig verliebt bist,
du rufst ihr, hey Baby, jetzt, wir beide brennen durch, ich bin reich.
So, dann auf dem Weg zur Lotto-Totto-Stelle, was sei denn jetzt, fucking Totto eigentlich. Was hat das, spielt jemand Totto? Das ist eine Band, Totto.
Hey Leute, ich habe mit dem Totto gewonnen!
Alle Rates! Zwei Euro, das war der Hauptgewinn, weil niemand spielt das. So, auf dem Weg zur Lotto-Toto-Annahmestelle verschluderst du das Ticket in deinem Auto. So, du kommst an und sagst, fuck, kriegst kein Geld, hast aber schon allen gesagt, dass du es hast. Musst jetzt also alle nochmal anrufen und sagen, ich habe leider das Ticket verschnudert. Oder nicht mehr hören. Oder nur noch 20% hören. Oh, ändert vieles. Aber so richtig, dass eigentlich... Aber im Online-Szenar hat ja auch kein Geld. Ich will ihn hören, ich will ihn normal hören, lieber das Verschnudern. Auf jeden Fall. Ja, das ist relativ einde jeden Fall. Ich habe neulich den Film von Kristen Wiig, Welcome to Me, geguckt. Und da geht es halt darum, dass eine Frau mit Borderline-Syndrom im Lotto gewinnt und dann ihre eigene Show macht auf so einem H24-Channel im Stile von Oprah Winfrey. Mega Idee, mega, mega Idee. Und der muss halt zwangsläufig damit beginnen, wie sie im Lotto gewinnt. Heißt, du siehst dich dann vorm Fernseher sitzen, Lotto spielen, hat dann so ein Klemmbrett, hat die Lottoscheine drin und guckt halt die Lottoziehung. Und die erste Zahl ist richtig, die zweite Zahl ist richtig, die dritte Zahl ist richtig und du denkst halt vorm Fernseher, no way. Du denkst halt, du guckst den Film und denkst, no fucking way. Ich akzeptiere diese Filmprennungsprämisse nicht. Aber es gewinnen ja Leute im Lotto.
Ja, klar.
Und es ist so unwahrscheinlich.
Und dann siehst du das und selten wird dir so vor Augen geführt,
wie unwahrscheinlich gerade der Film ist, den du guckst.
Aber das ist in dem Moment, natürlich braucht es der Film,
natürlich gibt es das auch und es ist nicht so unrealistisch.
Es ist natürlich eine coole Geschichte zu erzählen.
Und wir springen ja auch in den Filmen,
wo diese Geschichte spielt, die erzählenswert ist.
Aber du glaubst es einfach nicht.
Du akzeptierst diesen Moment einfach nicht. Darum ist ja auch interessant, es gibt ja dieses Phänomen von El Gordo in der mexikanischen Lotterie. Auch bei 99% Invisible kann man das anhören. Ein guter Podcast noch mal empfohlen, 99% Invisible. Da gibt es irgendwie die Lotterie in Mexiko. Das ganze Nacht hat Lotto gespielt und irgendwann hat die Regierung gesagt, hey, das läuft aus dem Ruder, die Leute geben zu viel Geld für Lotto aus, wir machen jetzt Lotto-Tickets sehr, sehr teuer, damit die Leute weniger Lotto spielen. Genau das Gegenteil ist eingetreten, die Leute haben jetzt nicht mehr alleine Lotto gespielt, sondern haben sich in Kommunen zusammengetan, um ein Lotto-Ticket zu kaufen. Und ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das ist wirklich ein Event, das ist wie Weihnachten, also Leute nehmen sich frei für die Lotto-Ziehung. Weil halt der ganze Ort zusammen fiebert und man trifft sich zusammen und man isst und man guckt die Lottozahlen und man gewinnt. Und eine Firma hat, also eine Stadt oder so hat ein Ticket, die hat eine Zahl. Und man kann wie bei Aktien auch Anteile von Tickets kaufen und von diesen Zahlen und alles mögliche. Und es gab einmal eine Lotteziehung, wo ein komplettes Dorf gewonnen hat. Alle in diesem Dorf haben wahnsinnig viel Geld bekommen, ausser eine Person. Eine Person in dem Dorf hatte kein Ticket, alle anderen Sachen. Und zwar auch die Begründung, nicht weil er keins kaufen wollte, sondern weil er so weit
weg gewohnt hat, dass diese Leute, die dafür
gesammelt haben, gingen halt nicht zu dem.
Und der hat als einziger nicht gewonnen. Und da denkst du dir
schon, scheiße. Aber vielleicht hat
er am Ende, vielleicht kann man da eine gute
Message draus ziehen, dass er am Ende das beste Leben hatte,
weil er auf dem Boden geblieben ist und
alle anderen, man denkt ja auch,
wenn du... Aber es sind nur 100.000 Euro,
es sind nicht Millionen. Ich glaube, 100.000 Euro ist nicht lebensverändernd. Ja, vielleicht für Leute, die mit dem Bauern gewohnt haben. Naja, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist, glaube ich, so, wahrscheinlich, wenn du wenig Geld hast oder normal viel Geld hast, denkst du, Geld löst alle meine Probleme. Und wenn du dann Geld hast, dann bist du enttäuscht davon, dass es nicht all deine Probleme löst. Und dann bist du wahrscheinlich unglücklicher als davor, weil du nicht mehr den Ausweg hast. Ja, weil du dann weißt nichts mehr und nichts mehr kann deine Probleme. Du hast keine Hoffnung mehr. Ich bin für immer verdammt unglücklich zu sein. Und damit vielen Dank an euch da draußen, dafür, dass ihr uns die ganze Zeit Geld gebt, und uns das Gefühl gebt, auch damit nicht glücklich zu sein. Wenn ihr uns noch kein Geld gebt, könnt ihr das auf patreon.com slash daspodcastufo immer gerne tun. Es gibt verschiedene Perks, die ihr freischalten könntet. Holt euch die Perks! Ja, da müssen wir uns noch ein bisschen ... Es haben schon drei Leute geschrieben, dass sie ein Share von uns verdient haben. Einer hat sich eingekauft. Einer hat sich für 300 Euro, das kann man auch in dieser Folge eingekauft, der kommt bald zu Besuch. Das müssen wir noch klären und ansonsten wir gucken, wie das weiterführt. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das in der Community gut ankommt, wenn sich jemand einkauft in der Folge. Weiß ich nicht, aber das ist ja auch der Gag ein bisschen. Wenn Sellout obvious ist, dann ist es auch wieder immer noch Sellout. Es ist kein Sellout mehr. Naja, wer weiß. Dann ist es nur noch lustig. Hey Leute, wünschen euch eine wunderschöne Woche und gute Fahrt, gute Reise, kommt gut durch die Woche. Und zieht euch das Richtige an. Ich glaube, diese Woche ist so ein typischer Sweater, ja, typischer, Sweater lange Hose. Noch kein Schal, Sweater ist auf jeden Fall da, Stefan Titzel war mit am Start.
Und die Dichtensneaker, ja.
Und vielen Dank, bis nächste Woche, haut rein, macht's gut, weheben ab!
Show, weheben ab!
Vergessen, letzte Mal!